how many of you were nervous coming into
the mosque are you Jesus and he says I
am but relationship okay I would love
everyone here to be a Muslim I had to
follow Islam bacon I said he
he said it was like his third fourth
time visiting but he said the first time
you visit he was really scared because
he had a lot of negative things that he
heard pumped up with Fox News and all
many of the other pundits out there hey
provocateurs
I call him and but he pushed through
that he found the courage he made the
human connection and he came into a
mosque how many of you were nervous
coming into the mosque yah okay how many
felt pretty pretty comfortable okay so
we're at about fifty fifty that's good
so mosque is pretty much a house of God
a house of worship
this is where Muslims come to worship
the one God the one creator
what's the purpose of my life why am I
here it starts with those questions
it starts with thinking deeper besides
materialism satisfy satisfying one's
desires and wants and needs eat food
sleep it goes above and beyond that for
the intellectual for the person s
sincere the one who wants to know the
person who wants to lose reflects deeply
please the person who looks around them
and I usually challenge people with this
to find one thing around you that
doesn't have a purpose from the keys in
your pocket to the chain on your neck to
your eyelashes above your eyes to your
shoelaces in your shoes everything
around you you see has a purpose but
then the human being thinks what's my
purpose so it starts with that wanting
to know why have I been created why am I
here how many people believe that we
should be grateful and thankful to the
Creator and we should strive our best to
submit our will to the one God to the
Creator how many raise your hand yeah
okay good so you believe everyone should
be a Muslim because that's what a Muslim
is literally a Muslim is one who submits
his or her will to the will of the
critic
meaning I'm gonna do what God wants me
to do I'm not going to follow my desires
and Islam means to submit your will to
the will
this is what it's loud piece acquired by
submission to the will of God this is
what it means simply but we say that the
concept of submission to the will of God
Islam was there from the first man Adam
this was the original wait a natural way
that God Almighty created Adam and what
did he do he called him to submit his
will to God and that message was
consistent and it stayed like that and
when you mankind deviated from that god
almighty out of his love he would send
another messenger and that messenger
didn't come with a different religion or
a different way he would call him
worship the One God
there's no deity worthy of worship
except the one who created you
you don't worship money fame you don't
worship yourself your desires human
beings angels Saints nothing in creation
but the one God the one creator thou
shalt have no gods except the one guy
the Muslim evaluates it puts it to the
test of human being poses to the test
there's only four possibilities that
either the Quran which claims to be from
God has a falsification test in it to
say hey if you think it's not from the
Creator do this this and this there's
one very powerful ayah we say verse that
says FL a yeta that Beruna quran god
almighty is saying in the original
language it was revealed in do they not
reflect over the Quran had it been from
other than Allah then the crater you
would find in it many contradiction
discrepancies a challenge find one and
other things that are mentioning there
from the development of the human being
to biology zoology and the list goes on
of too many things that would be
compiled together that a man living in a
desert fourteen hundred years ago
because that's one of the possibilities
leader Muhammad himself he wrote it he
was known as El Amin he wasn't able to -
he was the unlettered known by his
people as the truthful the honest of the
most noble character we look at his life
we say ok the Muslim look the human
being look says there's no way Muhammad
could have come up with his book a group
of people came together to
this book the best of minds God Almighty
sing in the Quran challenging
human-beings if you think this is from
other than God go ahead produce one
chapter like it or anything like it come
bring all of your helpers if you could
you won't be able to and another test so
then a third option it's from the devil
that's the third option and then a
person uses his logic his or her logic
and sees hold on the book is calling me
to worship one guy to be morally upright
to be good righteous human being to
everything Noble and good we seek refuge
from the cursed devil says I will the
billahi min ash-shaitani rajeem o
seeking refuge into the in God from the
accursed devil
so everything that the devil is calling
us to do god almighty the crimes calling
us opposite it doesn't make sense so
then there's only one option so the
human being finds out hold on if it
wasn't for Mohammed he couldn't have put
it together not from a group of men or a
group of people who else is in there
philosophers what not then who else from
the devil himself there's only one
option so the human being sees that this
Quran is indeed from who it claims to be
from the creator of the heavens and
earth for you would be a potential book
for the other close to 1.8 2 billion
people human beings for them they've
confirmed that this is indeed based on
proof and evidence it's not something
that's just meant for the Arab that's
another misconception so we covered one
already to that people feel - people
believe that the Islam is for the Arabs
Arabs make up maybe 12 13 % so you have
Muslim a Muslim again could be from
Italy could be from America can be from
where where my family's from Bosnia were
actually the largest group of Unitarian
Christians in the balkans at one time
see they were considered heretics by the
church because they didn't go to the
church to worship they didn't believe
Jesus was God they loved Jesus but they
didn't believe he was the literal God
they believed in the God that Jesus
worship they were Unitarian Christians
they were called Bogomils those close to
God
so there was a specialist very
interesting history I visit there a lot
and I spoke to many historians and he
they all pretty much did the same
recollection the same historical facts
so when when Islam came it fit like a
glove and you had sixty thousand at one
time of these Unitarian Christians those
who just worship the one God who
accepted Islam so now we confirmed this
and then you have the example of Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
the same way if you were living turn the
time of Jesus
you would have to he was the way the
truth and the light you couldn't bypass
him to get to God
whatever he came with you have to go
ahead and implement this in your life
and follow his teachings the same during
the time of Moses today we have the
Quran the verbatim Word of God Almighty
and the example it's like you get a book
with the iPhone and now there's a
representative teaching you how to
implement the book and this is how
Mohammed fits in another misconception
if some people have is that Muslims
worship Muhammad this would be the and
this would be one of the the
unforgivable unpardonable sins if
someone dies in its setting of a partner
with God so in Islam is pure monotheism
that all of your worship my life my
death God Almighty you think is only for
the god of Jesus the god of Moses the
God of Abraham the god of Mohammed but
Mohammed is a Messenger of God teaching
us how to worship God how to live our
lives just like that representative like
Jesus was at his time he said that we
came to free people from the worship of
creation to the worship of the Creator
so to take people from worshipping
materialism the creation anything under
the Sun anything that's created to
direct that worship from that those
things and being a slave to those things
to direct that back to the creator and
to free people from the restricts the
tightness of this world and to the
vastness of the next life to be in this
world as a traveler because we're going
to leave we're going to depart this life
is temporary so don't abandon it all
together you don't have to be a monk or
be so hermit someone who's locked up in
a vase
locked up in a mosque all day but Islam
gives us the blueprint how to live our
lives to again to worship the One God to
be morally upright in business in family
and all of the interactions that we have
with other human beings everything is
there
so then you have the the prayer five
times a day
the Bible says pray see singly right so
this is it you're in a state that not
you're not just praying you know all day
and all night but now you have that a
fixed time you can have the extra
prayers but you're in a constant state
of remembrance so prayer five times a
day fasting during the month of Ramadan
and the Bible word has it that Jesus
went off and fast at how many days so
you have fasting during the month of
Ramadan and then the Hajj this is the
pilgrimage to the first house of worship
once in your lifetime if you're
physically and financially able I mean
how many people love Jesus raise your
hands and every time you say Jesus we
say peace be upon him and this is a
thing that that you know another common
thing that that it's an article of faith
for Muslims to believe in Jesus
you see Jesus reiterating when one came
to him in the Gospel of Matthew said oh
good master referring to Jesus what good
thing can I do that I may have eternal
life Jesus is why you calling me good
there's none good with God and if one
wants to enter into eternal life meaning
to get to Jenna to Paradise one must
obey the commandments so then you see
the same thing god almighty is saying in
the Bible you hear when one came to him
said what is the grace of the grace of
commandment said hear o Israel the Lord
thy God is one so you hear Moses saying
it here o Israel the Lord thy God is one
it's repeated so Jesus copied the same
thing we'd say no he's just reiterating
the same truth so he's we're iterating
the same truth when it came to Jesus he
repeated the same thing here o Israel
the Lord thy God is one Mohammed same
thing thou shalt have no other gods
except the one God worship Him alone
without any partners
working relationship beautiful beautiful
so where's the where's the we have this
constant where when a human being gets
to know God and it's not just because
people want to they want to talk to God
but they don't want to listen to God
there's a difference right we just want
to talk when we're told what to do
nobody's listening so then we bring it
back and we look at you know the
different and really at the end of the
day it really boils down to - we've made
it easy
it's Christianity and Islam these are
the two you have Judaism and know the
the ones that will claim that they were
the monotheistic ways of religions all
right so now it's up to you to say okay
with a sincere heart and mind to ask the
crater alone to guide me now you start
examining you start to look into it with
God's help and now you come to it and
once you get to know God let's say you
get to know him through the Quran you
cannot help but look and when you love
God now you won't obey God because how
can you love your mother
if you don't know B you see how can you
love your parent how can you love
someone you're married but you just want
to do what you want to do and then you
go get the gift that's good let's say
for example the person you're you're
your wife tomorrow you guys get married
your husband
it is diabetic you get these nice
chocolates you like them a lot alright
you didn't take the time off to go and
see what that person really loves but
you got what you love so now you take
that you know they're diabetic they
can't eat it say I can't eat they will
all eat it I love you it doesn't make
sense
[Music]
we have to find out this human being
what God because we get to know God then
we love God now through knowing God
because it's not where we can do we just
end up doing Jumping just for God
push-ups for God we do where am I going
you know that currency has to be
transferable yes a person can have a
good intention but it has to be based on
knowledge the right knowledge the right
intention and the right action
so these combined will get us where we
need to go how we get to know God is to
what he revealed about himself so the
main thing is we don't separate God and
put him in this place at that place the
the the the the oneness of God is
something is inseparable how we get to
know God is through his attributes so he
is the most just he's the most kind he's
the most merciful and when we say he
it's not a male or female okay but this
is just how you would describe in the in
the English language because otherwise
we say it so you gotta put you know
because how the English language word
you say he but there's no but there is
no gender with God follow me there's a
beautiful verse in the Quran where and
repeated in Arabic and why I do that is
because Mithen tissa T and how we have
it in its original and that's the
beautiful thing about Islam -
authenticity of it is where God Almighty
is saying again you say a little bit
about him in the shaytani regime it
starts off the chapter we see I seek
refuge with with God from the accursed
devil
bismillahirrahmanirrahim in the name of
God the most compassionate Most Merciful
who Allahu Ahad Allah who summit Lemire
laid well mu allah dwell in the
hula-hooper when i had say he is god the
one and only the absolute the eternal
the self-sufficient he begets not nor is
He begotten meaning he's not the father
of anyone nor was he father and there's
nothing comparable to him this is a
beautiful this is how we get to know God
through the verbatim word of God through
the Quran and what he says about himself
because I can just go ahead and talk
about anybody here but that I didn't
bother to read your authentic biography
and I'm making that stuff as I go along
you follow me
so as Muslims
make sure that we stick to what God says
about himself and that's how we do
justice to God God spoke to us through
the Quran so to all of us spoke to you
to me to all of us whoever opens up the
Quran God is speaking to you for you
guys will be is that I would ask you to
look at it as a potential book from God
intellectual laziness would be like you
know I'm just going to put it to the
side you should examine it as a
potential book to you from the crater
pick it up with a good translation right
there's two women to who accepted Islam
it's called site from sake international
or clear Quran calm and read it in the
English language right you remember from
19 from 1800 to 1950 Time magazine did
an article exposing that and bringing to
light that over spend 150 years there
was 60,000 books written against Islam
60,000 books so you have to be really
careful that's one book a day imagine
that was at a time when you didn't have
social media you didn't have Facebook
and all the other tools that are out
there imagine how much how much junk you
know to get to the treasure now all of
this is piled up so you're going to be
affected by that and there are also
people with a deliberate attempt to try
to distort many of the words but so you
have to look at a really good
translation because you guys can't
obviously read the original you know you
know the Arabic but a good translation
with the author's humble attempt to go
ahead and translate it to the best
meaning possible and then a person looks
at it and says hey man you know this is
either something that's indeed accurate
it's right or it's not at least you give
your your heart arrest a peace of mind
Jesus said I am the way the truth the
life no man comes to the Father but
through me and in another passage when
he was approached by the guards in the
Garden of Gethsemane they asked are you
Jesus and he says I am but he's not just
saying I am as endure he's actually
quoting previous scriptures so he's
saying that I am God
remember when I said there's verses that
can be ambiguous and then there's verses
that are clear we would say look every
prophet or messenger that was sent by
God Almighty they were the way the truth
and the life
you could not bypass Abraham if you were
living during his time he was the way
the truth and the light meaning light
bringing the guidance and the way to God
so I can't say well I'm just gonna buy a
pass and do my own thing if you were
living in during the time of Moses you
cannot just bypass Moses to get to God
you have to follow his teachings the
same thing during Jesus's time you had
to obey Him not worship Him you had to
go through him through his teachings to
get to God that's how we would interpret
this right and during now during prophet
muhammad's during this time we would say
the way to God through the teachings of
Prophet Muhammad now to worshiping him
or sorting saving a partner with him but
do his teaching
[Music]
when Paul encountered Jesus in the New
Testament he was sent to the Jew and the
Gentile which means the boys he is he
one thing though okay can I just answer
it like that for you this leads us into
a whole different discussion now we
would come to the authenticity of the
Bible people of course call the gospel
books Matthew Mark Luke and John well
they call the Matthew Mark Luke and John
because we don't know who wrote these
books and there's no point calling them
Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean they're
they're written by people we don't know
who they were written by they are
anonymous you might not think so because
they have the title the Gospel according
to Matthew whoever put that title on it
was an editor later the followers of
Jesus were Aramaic speaking peasants
from Galilee lower-class men who were
not educated in fact Peter and John in
Acts chapter 4 verse 13 are literally
said to be illiterate they couldn't read
and write of course not there were
fishermen they didn't go to school the
vast majority of people in the ancient
world never learned to read let alone
write and their native language was
Aramaic these books are written in Greek
by highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in Greek
composition see this will bring us to a
whole different like John 1:1 for
instance if you take and and remember
guys when I come at this I know this can
sometimes this is when we express and we
shares because we care it's because I
would love everyone here to be a Muslim
and to follow Islam a statement from
Prophet Muhammad where he says one is
not a true believer until he loves for
his brother for Humanity sister what he
loves for himself hey it's not work now
I'm trying to win a debate
we come from sincere genuine concern and
love and from truth when we feel that
this is a hundred percent from the
crater and it's for everyone so we want
to share it so when I mentioned these
points when we talk about let's say John
1:1 in the beginning was the word if we
take word and we just replaced her God
the beginning was God and then God was
with God and God became God you see when
we look into the textual when we get
into the area of textual criticism and
you look at it this is a very debatable
book that you cannot attribute this even
to John so we don't even know many of
these books are an animus books like for
instance many people and you can look
this up on your own this is not Muslims
make you know Bible scholars will tell
us that the for example one one point of
Matthew Mark Luke and John
many people are the assumption that
Matthew wrote Matthew Mark wrote mark
and etc but these are anonymous books we
don't have the original so we don't have
the original gospel of Jesus so this is
where now the point of contention and we
say this is why God Almighty sent the
Quran because man it's not your fault
it's not his fault or her fault but
human beings have changed the words
certain human beings have altered that's
why and this answers your question why
God Almighty sent the Quran where it's
preserved it's in its original form for
humanity to investigate and to look at
scrutinize and then to conclude at the
end if they're sincere humble and they
they want to note that this is indeed
from the Creator go ahead and it's up to
you guys at the end I meant some of
these references from the Bible but then
it gets going back and forth is gonna
mean this you mean that but in a
nutshell when we compare it and we give
it the holistic approach right we come
to the conclusion that there's one
creator sent messengers Mohammed being
the last and there's enough evidence
there for any human being to evaluate it
to screw that then at the end we get the
elephant out of the room right we go
ahead and my Christian comes to tell it
to tell me that if he loves me he says
look believe in Jesus are you going to
help
I'll shake his hand hey man the guys
telling me cuz he loves me right on why
should I be angry with him you get it to
put the same thing now that's the saint
if we deny Jesus as Muslims then at the
end of the day I can end up in the
Hellfire but at the same time Prophet
Muhammad he also said the one that you
or the Christian the one who hears about
me right who denies me same thing
they'll have the same thing we would we
come back and say that person will be
consequence into Hellfire this is that
authentic so we out of the love we
shared the same thing but now you
respect that man these guys they don't
curse for Jesus they honor him in the
Blessed Mother they actually want to
strive to make society a better place
right to preaching good morals and
manners and ethics right we had disagree
on this we can leave that debate
sometimes at the dinner table but we
move on if we don't agree to all their
bigger things right we got so many
things that are destroying our families
in society but we're gonna be stuck over
here on these disputes we shared our
message you shared yours at the end of
the day who gives the business to the
Hellfire me no put the guy before me so
it's in God's hands
you follow me
[Applause]
god bless me really you know and I'm a
Muslim
that's 1998 my god save us all thank you
so much I appreciate having Eddie here
to help explain what the Muslim faith is
how they practice to help us relate in
our understanding within our culture and
the way that that we've been taught to
build some bridges of understanding and
actually I felt personally that I was
invited to understand from a new
perspective so I would definitely
and encourage people to come listen read
well study well think and ask God for
insight revelation MC C's been nothing
but gracious and friendly they're great
hosts as most Muslims are their hosts
very nice I would totally recommend
anybody to come check it out meet people
ask questions and yeah totally open to
invite anybody